[Música]
Bienvenidos a exclusivo francés 24 hoy
desde el foro económico mundial con el
presidente de Costa Rica Rodrigo Chávez
presidente Muchas gracias por atendernos
le pregunto primero bueno su
participación en este foro que ha
logrado conseguir o que ha logrado para
Costa Rica hemos logrado muchísimo
Daniela primero un gusto estar con usted
con su audiencia hemos posicionado a
Costa Rica ante la comunidad
internacional como lo que somos un país
democrático de respeto a los derechos de
todos los individuos de Gran
sostenibilidad ambiental un destino
turístico
fabuloso y sobre todo en la sociedad
donde hay ley orden y apego al derecho
por un lado por otro lado estamos
haciendo conversaciones obteniendo
conversaciones muy importantes con
grandes inversionistas las compañías más
grandes del mundo para continuar
atrayendo inversiones extranjera directa
a Costa Rica Por qué Porque lo que
queremos es generar
prosperidad empleos para los
costarricenses presidente usted está
casi que recién llegado al cargo o no ha
cumplido de ni siquiera un año pero
quiero preguntarle cómo recibió el país
y cómo está en ese momento Cuál es el
balance que usted puede dar bueno
nosotros Yo he sido muy claro yo soy una
persona muy transparente Daniela yo dije
que el país lo había recibido en un
desorden total
y temas Fiscales temas de prioridad en
el uso de los recursos la calidad del
gasto la calidad de los servicios que el
estado costarricense le daba al pueblo
hemos logrado
avanzar mucho por ejemplo Costa Rica no
había tenido un superávit primario que
significa empezar a pagar la deuda
pública que se acumuló por 40 años no
habíamos tenido no habíamos abonado a
nuestro deuda pública en quince años o
13 años este año ya pudimos hacer un
abono en el 2022 entre 2 y un 2.3 2.3%
del pib hemos bajado las tarifas
eléctricas sustancialmente 30% en
promedio
las instituciones están dando mejores
servicios y Daniela no es por presumir
no lo dice Rodrigo Chávez lo dice el
pueblo de Costa Rica que nos está dando
un apoyo sin precedente en la historia
de nuestro patria sí tiene nivel de
popularidad bastante alto y Costa Rica
pues es destacado siempre se ha
destacado por ser una democracia
bastante
pues bastante ejemplar para el resto de
la región ahora Quiero preguntarle una
democracia bastante ejemplar pero
también difícil el costarricense es
difícil de complacer y el hecho de que
haya un apoyo popular tan apabullante a
nosotros nos da esperanza de que es una
señal que vamos en la ruta correcta
igual si la
Seguiremos haciendo lo que haya que
hacer por el país pero si sentimos que
una democracia tan competitiva pues
tenemos casi Que 200 años de democracia
sin interrupción esto no tiene
precedente y Estamos contentos
presidente usted cómo ve todo ese viraje
hacia la izquierda que ha dado América
Latina cómo va a ser eso qué papel va a
jugar en los próximos años en términos
políticos y también económico mire yo
soy
un
demócrata de corazón ferviente hay gente
que confunde la democracia que es las
reglas del juego y dice la democracia es
el resultado del juego No señores la
democracia son las reglas del partido el
resultado del partido lo que estamos
viendo los pueblos de América Latina han
escogido con votos claros en elecciones
libres y nosotros como costarricenses
y particularmente un pueblo democrático
lo aceptamos tenemos que adaptarnos a
eso Costa Rica ha estado de manera
insistente en los últimos ocho meses de
mi gobierno
y tratando de integrarse más al mundo
abriendo fronteras estamos a punto de
firmar un tratado comercial de un
tratado de libre comercio con este
Ecuador está ya solicitamos ingreso a la
alianza del Pacífico la app estamos
esperando que se resuelva la presidencia
pro tempore del traslado de México a
Perú estamos también ya solicitamos
ingreso a la iniciativa de ctp en Asia y
le señalamos a los Estados Unidos que
queremos entrar y a México y a Canadá en
el arreglo de México Canadá de Estados
Unidos que es un tratamiento comercial
de
fluidez en nuestras relaciones Costa
Rica se sigue abriendo el mundo Yo
espero que los otros países de América
Latina lo vean como en los ojos esa
integración que queremos claro y
Precisamente hay hay un tema que
saliéndonos un poco de la economía hay
un tema que preocupa a muchos ciudadanos
en este país es la seguridad
es uno de los países en donde más está
creciendo los crímenes por cada 100.000
habitantes que están haciendo para para
controlar esta situación mire eso es un
tema que es muy del momento es un tema
de actualidad tenemos que ser claros lo
que está ocurriendo es un aumento muy
fuerte en
los ajustes de cuentas y la guerra entre
bandas de narcotráfico
por mercado por el robos de cocaína
mayoreo este que una banda se la robó a
otro y ahí es donde está creciendo la
inseguridad nosotros tenemos un plan muy
ambicioso para evitar que Costa Rica
siga siendo un lugar de exportación de
cocaína de trans shipment que llega a
Costa Rica dice manda a los mercados de
Europa de Estados Unidos eso es conocido
en Costa Rica y creemos que por ahí
podemos empezar a atacar el tema de los
asesinatos tenemos un plan que vamos a
anunciar en 15 días más o menos para
entrarle con fuerza y vigor a esto
es lamentable pero yo quiero que la
gente que nos está viendo sepa Cuál es
la causa de esta situación tan terrible
que es violencia entre narcotraficantes
sobre todo y han tratado de Buscar
acuerdos con otros países para trabajar
conjuntamente en esta situación bueno
nosotros estamos trabajando con los
Estados Unidos pero es nuestra
responsabilidad la estrategia consiste
en no permitir que la cocaína que
ingresa al país salga exportada en
contenedores
nosotros no tenemos Marina no tenemos
fuerza aérea no tenemos ejército como
para sellar nuestras fronteras de la
cocaína que viene del sur de América del
Sur particularmente Colombia y entonces
nuestra estrategia no permitir que salga
en contenedores Y eso le va a quitar
valor agregado a las bandas criminales y
Esperamos que con eso se reduzcan los
problemas
presidente con la guerra en Ucrania hubo
qué afectación para Costa Rica
en Ucrania afectó a todo el mundo
tuvimos este problema de precios de
inflación de alimentos tuvimos aumentos
sustancia en los combustibles
crea incertidumbre temor en los
inversionistas problemas geopolíticos
Sin embargo a nosotros nos ha ido bien
dentro de lo que cabe nuestra inflación
fue de el ocho por ciento
aproximadamente no fue de las más altas
usted sabe como experta en el tema que
muchos países tuvieron una enorme
inflación la moneda se nos ha apreciado
contrario al peso contrario al peso
chileno al peso colombiano contrario a
la mayoría de las monedas del mundo
contra el dólar Nosotros hemos tenido
una apreciación del Colón
bastante
significativa pasamos de 700 colones a
586 colones hoy saque la cuenta es un
porcentaje muy significativo producto de
la confianza que está generando
las políticas de gobierno más bien
tenemos que pensar para Qué hacer para
que no se siga apreciando el colón claro
y dos preguntas en una
ese está llegando más inversión lo que
hace que se esté apreciando la moneda y
con la pandemia pues se afectó mucho el
turismo que es uno de los renglones
económicos más importantes Cómo están en
este momento usted lo tiene claro Hay un
repunte importante el turismo por lo
tanto nuestros ingresos están aumentando
en dólares hay también bastante
inversión
y muchos costarricenses repatriando
dólares ante la certeza que les da el
gobierno
en pocas palabras para la gente que
entiende estas cosas la oferta de
dólares ha subido y por lo tanto el tipo
de cambio que el Banco Central Deja que
se fije en el mercado nos ha apreciado
el colón Eso es bueno para algunos los
precios de los combustibles han bajado
producto de esto para el consumidor los
préstamos que en Costa Rica hay muchos
denominados en dólares se convierten más
accesibles más baratos y entonces
estamos discutiendo qué hacia adelante
pero es una buena señal en principio
presidente usted de los optimistas o
pesimistas frente a la recesión mundial
en 2023 vea Costa Rica es un país de 5.2
millones de habitantes
nosotros lo que hacemos Es
adelantarnos a los eventos en la medida
en que eso se pueda mantenernos ágiles y
responder con las medidas de política
pública adecuadas yo soy muy optimista
que si no hay recesión nos va a ir muy
bien y que si hay recesión la vamos a
saber manejar muy bien y por eso viene a
davos a mí no me gusta sentarme al país
7 días pero si se contrae el pastel de
inversiones extranjera directa yo no
solo quiero llevarme la tajada que
teníamos antes sino una tajadita Tal vez
hasta más grande y para eso es la
competencia eso nos hace mejor a todos
presidente Muchas gracias por estar en
Francia 24
muchísimo gusto saludarle a Daniela un
placer un saludo a su audiencia y a las
a las órdenes suyas siempre a ustedes
también gracias por su sintonía quédense
en France 24 también puede consultar
esta entrevista en France 24.com
[Música]